(explosions)
- Rare exercice pour
de nouvelles recvelles recrues :
une simulation des horreurs qui
les attendent en Ukraine.
Dans quelques jours, cet homme
sera à Kiev avec l'un des
bataillons d'étrangers luttant
contre les forces russes.
Alekseï, juge très mauvais
qu'une armée envahisse le pays,
tue ses citoyens. Il est
lui-même un simple citoyen
biélorusse, touché par
le sort de ses frères slaves.
Exilé en Belgique, Alexeï
laisse un emploi et deux
adolescents derrière lui.ui.ui.
"Pas d'excuse, c'est au front
qu'il faut aller".
Alexeï intègre un bataillon
l des exilés comme lui,
tous opposés au régime prorusse
d'Alexandre Loukachenko.
Un bataillon inspiré de Kastous
Kalinowski, héros national de l.
L'un de ceux qui les recrute,
c'est cet homme.
Des volontaires, Pavel Cuttat
en a vu des dizaines passer,
tous prêts à combattre
aux côtés des Ukrainiens.
Vestes de protection, vêtements,
nécessaires de survie,
tout est donné par les exilés
bélarusses, qui seraient
plus de 400 000 en Pologne.
Dès l'invasion de la Crimée
par l'armée russe en 2014,
des Bélarusses s'étaient joints
aux soldats ukrainiens.iniens.i.
Pavel Cuttat y était,
il y a été blessé.
Cette fois, il reste à Varsovie.
Une contribution logistique
à l'effort de guerre.
voit pas qu'un combat
pour l'Ukraine, mais un combat
pour tout le Bélarus.
En 2020, le pays a été secoué
par la violente répression
de manifestations contrele prés,
un autocrate au pouvoir
depuis près de 28 ans.
Le régime au Bélarus ne peut
survivre sans Vladimir Poutine,
croit l'un des représentants
de l'opposition en exil.
Il espère une victoire  victoirs
Ukrainiens parce qu'elle
aiderait aussi aux efforts des
Bélarusses pour l'indépendance
et la démocratie de leur nation.
C'est aussi comme ça que de
nombreux volontaires voient
cette guerre...
"C'est une autre chance de
changer les choses", lance
Alexeï, prêt à don
pour l'Ukraine et le Bélarus.
Ici Yanick Dumont-Baron,
Radio-Canada, V